[Musique]
je m'appelle cool me bono et les douze
ans et je suis en syrie
j'adore ce sport me passionne depuis
lors des 6es mal à percer le riz et a
travaillé fort j'aime aussi beaucoup
voyagé
votre passion pour les voyages m'amène à
vous parler d'aidé qui est passé de
désert à un pays de rêve en très peu de
temps car j'avais 9 ans avec mon père je
regardais la télévision sur la
télévision il a un documentaire sur abu
dhabi
cela m'a intéressé on lui fait des
recherches et cela m'apporte a parlé du
pays qu'on appelle 50 ans est parti
depuis port de pêcheurs hadopi est
souvent riche de 14 plus prisés de dubai
tout est possible prenez l'exemple de
dubaï voici la ville en 1991 et la même
ville en 2018
toute cette évolution se fait quand 27
ans maintenant je veux tuer pour aller à
dubaï de québec
il faut prendre l'avion traverser
l'océan atlantique est allée à
l'aéroport de dubaï mais aussi on peut
faire un tous différents trajets en
bateau si vous avez un rêve
il faut travailler fort persister et un
jour il va se réaliser mais n'en parlons
de sa richesse du bas et devenir riche
en 1949 après la seconde guerre mondiale
ils ont trouvé du pétrole et de zap sort
en 1951 il faisait déjà 46 points 500
marines et pétrole par jour
avec cet argent il commence l évolution
en faisant les premières maisons écoles
et hôpitaux
dubai le premier pays des émirats arabes
unis
donc il est voici leurs deux drapeaux
les habitants de dubaï se nomme l'isara
lizotte porte indique d'achat est un
caissier tandis que les femmes portent
une abaya et hijab
maintenant je veux redire si ce record
de dubaï dubai les plus grandes et
belles et l'article du monde loue tu n
es plus luxueux du monde le burj al
ahmad un hôtel de cette étoile
cette étoile avec 57 étages de ça deux
chambres luxueuses cinq piscines et une
plage privée indienne et même une
plateforme pour hélicoptère ensuite la
burj khalifa la plus haute tour du monde
qui est de 830 mètres de haut
cent trente huit étages cinquante deux
ascenseurs et le dubai mall le plus
grand et cher et l'exerçant
d'achoppement qui a mille de sa boutique
plusieurs restaurants un aquarium et
même le centre de ski intérieur dubai al
aéroport ou plus grand trafic
international et la ville est reconnu
pour sa conception est clair maintenant
je veux dire cinq choses qu'on ne voit
pas par tout le monde
la jumeirah beach une des plus grandes
et belles plages monde qui a des cibles
ou le bridge en arabe
l'hôtel est alors le pandora lève
ensuite ski dubaï répète son de ski
intérieur en plein milieu du désert ou
qu'on peut s'amuser afin d'enclencher
neige du ski les batailles les plus
boule de neige et plusieurs autres
activités amusantes dans la neige
ensuite la fontaine de dubaï une des
plus grandes et belles fontaines du
monde qui peut être programmé à danser à
des chansons du bois là même son propre
legoland pour ceux qui se posent la
question legoland c'est quoi les goûts
l'année comme disneyland en plus petits
avec plusieurs conscient en lego à dubaï
et a même des machines avant des lingots
d'or ont choisi le carreau la grosseur
an payent et les sorties chaque fois un
blanc signifie je suis année et celui en
mauve signifie où je rêve d'aller
donc si vous avez bref il faut
travailler fort persister et un jour il
va se réaliser
merci
[Applaudissements]